over many videos now we've been talking
about how every interstellar object is
moving away from earth and we've also
been talking about how the further
something is away from Earth the faster
it's moving what I want to do in this
video is to put a little bit of a few
numbers behind or even better
conceptualize what we've been talking
about so one way to think about it is
that if at an early stage in the
universe
I were to pick some points so that's one
point another point another point
another point let me just pick let me
just pick nine points so that I have a
proper grid so this is an early at an
early stage in the universe if we fast
forward a few billion years and I'm
clearly not drawing it to scale all of
these points have all moved away from
each other so this point is over here
and actually let me draw another row let
me draw another row just to make it just
actually another column just to make it
clear so if we fast forward a few
billion years the universe has expanded
and so everything has moved away from
everything and let me color code it a
little bit let me make this point
magenta so this point the magenta point
is now here this green point has now
moved away from the magenta point and
now this blue point has now moved away
from the magenta point in that direction
and we could keep going this yellow
point is maybe over here now I think you
get the general idea and I'll just draw
the other yellow points so they've all
moved away from each other
so there's no center here everything is
just expanding away from things next to
it and what you could see here is not
only did this thing expand away from
this but this thing expanded away from
this even further because it had this
expansion Plus this expansion or another
way to think about it is the the
velocity with which the apparent
velocity with which something is
expanding is going to be proportional to
how far it is because every point in
between is also expanding away and just
to review a little bit of the
visualization of this one way to think
of this if you think of the universe as
an infinite flat sheet you can imagine
that we're just taking a
of I don't know some some type of sheet
of stretchy material and just stretching
it out we're just stretching it out
that's if we kind of imagine a more
infinite universe that just goes off in
every direction we're just rushing that
infinite sheet out so it has no
boundaries but we're still stretching it
out another way to visualize it and this
what we did earlier on is you can
imagine that this fear that the universe
is the three-dimensional surface of a
four dimensional sphere or the
three-dimensional surface of a hyper
sphere sort of an early stage in the
universe the sphere looked like this the
sphere looked like this and these points
here that magenta point is right over
here
the green point is right over there then
we had the blue point up here and then
let me just draw the rest of the yellow
points and the yellow points are here
they're all on the surface of this
sphere they're all on the surface of the
sphere obviously I'm only dealing with
two dimensions right now it's nearly
impossible or maybe impossible to
imagine a three-dimensional surface of a
four-dimensional sphere but then that
analogy holds if this is the surface of
a balloon or the surface of a bubble if
the bubble were to expand so if the
bubble were to expand over a few billion
years and not once again not drawn to
scale so now we have a bigger bubble
here this part of the surface is all
going to expand so once again you have
your magenta you have your blue dot you
have your green dot right over here and
then let me just draw the rest in yellow
so they will have all expanded away from
each other on the surface of this sphere
and just to make it clear this is a
sphere let me draw some contour lines so
this is a contour line just to make it
clear that we are on the surface we're
on the surface of an actual sphere now
with that out of the way let's think
about how fast or what is the apparent
velocity with which things are moving
away and remember we're gonna have to
say not only how far things are moving
away but we're going to say how far
they're moving it away from if the
observer is us depending on how how far
they already are so what we're going to
do we could say is
let me write this down all objects all
objects moving away from each other away
from each other and the velocity and the
apparent velocity the apparent the
apparent relative velocity relative
velocity is proportional is proportional
to distance proportional to a distance
and what I've just written down here and
this is why I wrote it down this is a
rephrasing of essentially Hubble's law
Hubble's Hubble's law and he came up
with this by just observing that when he
looks especially the further out he
looks the more redshifted objects are
and not only were they moving faster and
faster away from Earth but there were
they seem to be moving faster and faster
away from each other so this is just a
restating of Hubble's law or another way
to say it is from any point let's say
from the earth the velocity that
something appears to be moving is going
to be some constant is going to be some
constant times the distance times the
distance that it is away from the
observer in this case we are the
observer and we put this little zero so
this H here this H here is called
Hubble's constant Hubble's Hubble's
constant and it's a very non constant
constant because this constant will
change depending on where we are in the
evolution of the universe so we put this
little zero here this little sub-zero
right over here to show that this is
Hubble's constant right now and when we
talk about distance we're talking about
the proper distance right now proper
distance now and this has to be very
important because that proper distance
is constantly changing as the universe
expands so you know the now will
actually change slightly from the
beginning of this video to the end of
this video but we can roughly say in in
kind of our current period of time
and when we say proper distance we're
talking about if you actually had rulers
and if you were to just lay them down
instantaneously obviously we can't do
something like that
but we can imagine doing something like
that so that's what we're talking about
it so just just to give a sense of or
doing a little bit of math of how fast
things are actually moving apart the
current Hubble constant the current
Hubble constant is let me actually write
it where it's someplace where I have
more space
the current Hubble constant the current
Hubble constant is seventy point six
plus or minus plus or minus three point
one so we have observed some variation
here there is I guess some error to our
actual measurements kilometers
kilometers per second per per megaparsec
per mega mega parsec and remember a
parsec is roughly 3.2 3.3 lightyears so
another way to think about it is if this
is where we are in the universe right
now and if this is if this object right
over here if this distance right over
here is one mega parsec
so one million parsecs or 3.2 six
million light-years from Earth so this
is roughly so just so we have a sense
this is 3.2 6 roughly 3.2 6 million
light-years from Earth then this object
will appear to be moving away although
it's not moving in space just the space
that it's in is stretching in such a way
that it looks to be moving at 70 it's
look it looks like it's moving at 70
based on its redshift 70 point six
millimeters per second away from us so
this is a huge velocity 70 point 600
meters per second per second so this is
a and this is a pretty this is a pretty
fast velocity but you have to remember
this is over one mega parsec the
Andromeda galaxy is not even is not even
a mega parsec away it was about 2.5
million light years so it's about no
point
seven or 0.8 of a megaparsec so if you
look at a point in space a little bit
further than the Andromeda galaxy it
will look to be right now receding at
about seventy point six kilometers per
second but what if you were to go twice
that distance if you were to look at
something that's almost seven
light-years away to mega parsecs away so
if you look at if you were to look at
this object over here if you were to
look at this object over here how fast
would that be receding well if you just
look at it over here it's two mega
parsecs away so it's going to be twice
this you're just going to multiply its
distance to mega parsecs times this the
mega parsecs cancel out so seventy point
six times two is so it's going to be
moving it's going to look to be moving
it's not moving in space remember space
is just stretching so it's velocity its
apparent velocity will be seventy point
six times two so that's 141 point two
kilometres per second and this is you
know one question you say well how did
Hubble know you know it's easy to you
could observe the redshift of objects
moving away from us but how did he know
that they were moving away from each
other well if you were to look at the
redshift of this object say wow that's
moving away it's 70 point six kilometers
per second and then you look at the
redshift of this and say wow that's
moving away from us at 140 1.2
kilometers per second then you also know
that these two objects are moving away
from each other at 70 point six
kilometers per second and we could keep
doing this over different distances but
this hopefully this gives you a little
bit a more a little bit bigger sense of
things and just remember even though I
said this is a huge distance a mega
parsec is further than it is to the
Andromeda galaxy the Andromeda galaxy is
the nearest large galaxy to us there are
some smaller galaxies that are closer to
us that are kind of satellite galaxies
around the Milky Way but the Andromeda
is the largest galaxy is the nearest
large galaxy to us and we also know that
we're talking about hundreds of billions
of galaxies in just the observable just
the observable unit universe so very
quickly as you go near the edge of the
observable universe these these
velocities the the the apparent distance
at which things move
moving away from us start to become
pretty pretty significant